Kelly Clarkson is my wife's absolute
favorite
[Applause]
and this song makes her feel very
powerful
and not anymore
hanging man you know we're good friends
I'll be with you
until the end
yeah yeah
you know you're my boy
remember last week you were out of town
was that the house to help your mom out
yeah yeah
she needed my help
she said can you build some shelves I
said I don't know
[Music]
said you can still help me out dude I
[__] your mind myself
the same even the first time she likes
my dog yeah yeah
sorry man
we still be friends
sorry dude
and I [__] your mom
[Music]
are you out of your mind
[__] my mom and you think it's fine
yeah yeah
I want to punch her face
I know and I feel the same way
your mom and I we have something to say
hey
I'm pregnant
and we're in love
[Music]
I'm your new dad
I know it's weird cause we're the same
age but it'll be ready yeah yeah
friends
[Music]
all right